muy bien aquí tenemos una pequeña
arandela y esto es clásico tenemos una
pequeña arandela y la vamos a usar
porque distribuye mejor la fuerza del
tornillo lo cual nos puede ser útil
bien y aquí es cuando nos es de utilidad
tener una pinza de nariz de aguja
tomamos nuestro destornillador pequeño y
vamos a sostener la tuerca de este lado
lo volteamos y ahora apretamos el
tornillo con el destornillador queremos
asegurarnos de que quede bien ajustado
ya que si queda poco ajustado se va a
aflojar con el tiempo y va a hacer que
nuestros componentes se comiencen a
mover pienso que tiene lógica usar
tornillos largos ya que nos permitirá
montar nuestro arduino más arriba de lo
que podríamos si usáramos tornillos
menos largos y esto es útil porque
queremos evitar esto que sobresale y si
el arduino está más alto será más
sencillo acceder a su puerto usb
aquí es en donde podemos subir el código
la otra razón por la que queremos esto
alto es porque nos facilitará colocar
los cables por debajo si es que
necesitamos hacerlo y en este caso creo
que sí colocaremos algunos cables por
debajo
ahora vemos si cabe el arduino y si cabe
queremos que el arduino quede alto
y poder acceder bien al puerto usb
y lo vamos a hacer usando las mismas
tuercas que usamos para apretar los
tornillos para metal y los pondremos a
la misma altura para sostener nuestro
arduino queda más o menos así muy bien
ahora está a una altura que nos permite
acceder al puerto usb y colocar cables
abajo
pero antes de conectar el arduino
tenemos que colocar los motores
estamos poniendo el arduino en su lugar
y creo que los cables de energía lo
dejaremos por abajo o lo usaremos hacia
un lado
ahora ponemos las tuercas por encima en
los tornillos para mantener en su lugar
al arduino ops aquí vamos
vayan lo bueno es que este
destornilladores magnético muy bien ya
lo tenemos
parece que nos quedó un lado más alto
que el otro así que voy a ajustar el
tornillo para levantarlo un poco y nos
aseguramos de que todo esté a la misma
altura
vamos a ver si puedo poner una tuerca de
aquí y no hay muchas cosas alrededor de
este y mejor lo dejo así vamos a
probarlo aunque mejor aprieto bien las
tuercas ahora antes de que se me olvide
muy bien